I don't even own a home right now
um I'm literally staying at friends
places I I basically rotate through
friends spare bedrooms
um I really don't take vacations there
are just times when something is
important enough you believe in it
enough that you do it in spite of fear
if you just if you just accept the
probabilities
then that diminishes fear
so
um with starting SpaceX I thought the
odds of success were less than 10
percent
um and I just accepted that we actually
probably I would just lose lose
everything
um
but that maybe would make some progress
if we could just move the ball forward
even if we died Maybe
some other company could pick up the
Baton and move and keep moving it
forward so we'll still do some good
um yeah same with Tesla I thought the
odds of a car company succeeding were
extremely low people shouldn't think I I
I feel fear about this and therefore I
shouldn't do it
um it's normal to be to feel fear like
you'd have to definitely something
mentally wrong if you didn't feel fair
if somebody is doing something that is
useful to the rest of society I think
that's a good thing like it doesn't have
to change the world like you know
um if you're doing something that has
high value to people
um I do not expect to be involved in all
these things the five things that I
thought about at the time in in college
so quite a long time ago uh 25 years ago
um you know being you know making life
multi-planetary
um selling accelerating the transition
to sustainable energy
um the the internet broadly speaking
um
genetics and AI I think um I didn't
expect to be involved in in all of those
things I actually at the time in college
I sort of thought helping with
electrification of cars was how it was
set up and that's uh I really was just
trying to be useful that's the
optimization it's like what what can I
do that would actually be useful how
should someone figure out how they can
be most useful or whatever this thing is
that you're trying to create what would
what would be the
um utility Delta compared to the current
state of the art times how many people
it would affect
so that's why I think having something
that has that's that has a makes makes a
big difference but affects a sort of
small to moderate number of people is
great as is something that makes even a
small difference but it affects a vast
number of people what set of actions are
most likely to lead to a better future
you know in order for one of the things
obviously in order to for Humanity to
have a compelling future for
civilization is that we must have a
clear path to a sustainable energy
future it takes a very extremely
important very fundamental to the future
I try to say what I what I think is uh
you know a scientifically cogent even if
it is not popular some things are risky
but if this you know if the stakes are
important enough then you take the risk
well I think there's probably a lot of
people in this room that do take a lot
of risks anyway I literally just try to
use a scientific method frankly and you
know consider the you know what what is
the importance of the outcome and what
what is one risking in order to achieve
that outcome and but like I said if your
outcome is important enough even if the
probability of success is low one was I
think still still do it some things are
very important and if to in order to
have a good future and if we don't do
them well they're in big trouble and so
and then then how much the risk really
is it because if we don't take those
actions we want to have a good future
and I think the riskiest thing would be
no action
there's still a long way to go to
transition the world to a sustainable
energy economy and so
so we still have a lot of work ahead of
us at Tesla but that's that's our goal
there and then for SpaceX
um I think it's important for the for
the future for the future future to be
exciting and for humanities
um existence to be insured over the long
term I think we must become multi-planet
species and a space-bearing civilization
we've basically just been here for a
very brief instant we're a blink
all of human civilization is a blink of
an eye
if there wasn't I in in an evolutionary
time scale
so so I think it's important we take the
actions to ensure that the light of
Consciousness continues and because you
should we should really view
Consciousness as as a small candle in a
vast Darkness it's an easily go out I
actually think we're on a good path
um I but at the same time I I want to
want us to caution against complacency
so so long as we are not complacent as
long as we are have a high sales of
urgency about moving towards a
sustainable energy economy then I think
things will be fine
um so I I can't emphasize that enough as
long as we uh push hard uh and are not
complacent
um the future is going to be great the
the thing that is actually more more
difficult and and that does make
sleeping difficult is is that
um you know every good hour uh or even
minute of thinking about uh Tesla and
SpaceX has such a big effect on the
company that I really try to work as as
much as possible uh you know to to the
edge of Sanity basically in fact I don't
even own a home right now I'm literally
staying at friends places I if I travel
to the Bay Area which where most of
Tesla engineering is I stay in my I
basically rotate through friends spare
bedrooms
um I don't have a yacht I really don't
take vacations uh so
um it's not as though there's um that my
personal consumption is is high uh only
the one exception is a plane but if I
don't use the plane then I have less
hours to work I really want to make sure
that there is a good future for Humanity
um and that we're on a path to
understanding the nature of the universe
um the meaning of life why are we here
how do we get here and in order to
understand the nature of the universe
and
all these fundamental questions
we must expand the scope and scale of
Consciousness we certainly it must not
diminish or go out we we certainly we
won't understand this so I would say I'm
motivated by curiosity more than
anything
um and uh just a desire to think about
the future and
not be sad you know and are you are you
not sad I'm sometimes sad I I mostly I'm
I'm I'm feeling I guess
relatively optimistic about the Future
these days
there are certainly some big risks that
Humanity faces I think the population
collapse is a really big deal that I
wish more people would would think about
um because the birth rate is far below
us
much needed to sustain civilization it's
car at its current level you know
there's obviously a
and we need to take action on climate
sustainability which is is being done
and we need to secure the future of
Consciousness by being a multi-penet
species I I think if you care about the
reality of goodness instead of the
perception of it filmed throughout
philanthropy is extremely difficult
SpaceX Tesla neurolink reporting company
are philanthropy if you say philanthropy
is love of humanity
they are philanthropy